As our users, we know that sometimes code
is the best way to handle things.
And in this video walkthrough,
we'll be focused on setting up our access
to the rscloud package.
To get started using the rscloud package,
ee first need to set up
our client credentials,
and we do this from
within RStudio Cloud.
After logging in
to our RStudio Cloud account,
we can click on our icon or photo
in the top right to access the user panel
and then select client credentials.
This will take us to a page
with any existing credentials,
we might have. To create new credentials,
click on plus new credentials
in the top right.
This will open a pop up
where you can name your credentials.
After naming your credentials,
click OK to see and copy
your generated credentials.
You will only be shown
the credentials once.
So do be sure to
copy them and store them in a secure place
before closing the popup window.
Be careful not to share
or commit your credentials to git.
The recommended method for
setting your credentials is by editing
your R environ file.
And we can do this using the usethis package from within RStudio Cloud.
We can go to a project,
and by running
usethis::edit_r_environ() in the console.
This should then open your R environ file
where you can paste
and save your client credentials
before restarting R.
After setting up your credentials
in your R environ file,
you can install the development version
of the rscloud package by running
the following commands in the console:
install.packages("remotes") and
remotes::install_github("rstudio/rscloud")
Once this is done, you have the rscloud
package available and ready to use in RStudio Cloud.
From here, we can do things like run
rscloud_space_list(),
which will return a table
with all of the spaces
available within our
our RStudio Cloud account.
And we can use a space_ID
from this table to look at the number of
users and projects.
For example, when I run rscloud_space(81721),
I can see that there are 327 users
and 946 projects within this shared workspace.
You can learn more about additional
functionality of the rscloud package
by visiting the package
documentation at github.com/rstudio/rscloud